di solito storico locale e oggi vi
dobbiamo dire delle cose in più lo
faccio un bio waits dopo come ho chiesto
cosa vorreste ricevere in un giveaway mi
sono segnate un po di riso nel letto e
ha preparato delle cose per voi allora
primo vi dobbiamo dire delle cose quindi
assicuratevi vorrà il video fino alla
fine per sapere tutti gli annunci di una
cosa che mi devo dire no partecipanti ma
web è vero starete già scrivendo
parcheggi un bellissimo prima vediamo
dare le regole per partecipare bisogna
iscriversi e partecipare visivo
vi devo prima dire tutelare quello che
vorrei partecipare la prima cosa che mi
devo dire alcuni di voi lo sanno già
quelli che hanno accesso i miei post
della community e cerchiamo aperto un
secondo canale il canale per ora si
chiama anita stories 2 poi un po bruschi
nel bellissimo ma adatti o almeno
macinato ricordate cosa
e il nome scriverebbero secondo canale
quindi se volete consigliatemi pure
voglio lasciare l'inter stories però può
iscrivere qualcos'altro per
differenziarlo da questo quindi
consideratemi pure oppure lo lascio due
non lo so comunque secondo canale andate
iscrivervi vi lascio il link nella
descrizione del video qua sotto
andate iscrivervi perché è una regola
del giveaway e iscrivervi al secondo
khan e quindi andare subito ad
iscrivermi perche appare sul secondo
canale perché farò dei video il lunedì e
il martedì
nel secondo canale qui un video tutti i
giorni continueranno però il lunedì e
martedì saranno il secondo canale non in
questo principale che tipo di video
saranno saranno dei tipi di video che ho
già fatto su questo canale ma che non
faccia da un pozzetto su questo canale
ma vi farò nel secondo canale rai mi
riferisco è nato tutto quanto santo non
di non miri mancati divide solo perché
non scoprirete una volta che li
pubblicherò lì però voglio appunto
differenziarli e non mischiare il tutto
qua quindi saranno nel secondo canale
voi iscrivetevi e li vedrete è presto
attivati alcuna notifica perché una
volta che siete appena iscritti non
sempre vi avvisa che c'è un nuovo video
quindi attivate la notifica
stava scherzando
una delle novità
il secondo canale in cui farò dei tipi
di video solo lì quindi iscrivetevi
attivatela campanellina un'altra novità
che vi dobbiamo dire e se avete visto il
nostro video in cui vi spiego perché non
stavo facendo più video da un po di
tempo vi abbiamo accennato già una cosa
e cioè che uscirà una serie di banalità
store ed è una cosa pazzesca che non
potete nemmeno immaginare
mi hanno detto appunto che ti avrei dato
degli aggiornamenti piano piano brescia
che vi avrei spiegato allora è ancora in
elaborazione perché non sono solo io che
ci sto lavorando si stanno lavorando ad
altre persone però è una cosa pazzesca
però che richiede un sacco di tempo e un
sacco di lavoro
non posso dirvi il motivo il perché
perché voglio che sia tutta una sorpresa
però possiamo dire che ci siamo quasi
quasi 100 siamo vicini sarà una cosa
pazzesca che non avete mai visto una
cosa che non è mai stata fatta prima
d'ora questo tipo di serie quindi
scrivete pure nei commenti indovinate
chi è serie sarà tenendo a mente che è
una cosa che non è mai stata fatta prima
d'ora su youtube quindi che serie
potrebbe essere vediamo keyless
indovinare perché dell'altro video
nessuno ha indovinato è una cosa
talmente originale nuova che nessuno ha
indovinato quindi voglio vedere se in
questo video qualcuno indovinate di
questa è l'altra novità poi vi vogliamo
anche dire che nel canale prideaux
vedrete nuovi video ancora più belli
ancora più entusiasmanti ancora più
fantastici stiamo programmando di fare
altri tipi di video ancora più belli con
gli enti tra poco vedrete sempre più
video ovvero più belli e fantastici mi
raccomando campanella attivata sempre
per non perdere i basij
se non avete visto berlino non vi
preoccupate è uscito fuori a correre
musarò e perché c'è una bellissima
giornata di sole oggi quindi sta
rincorrendo gli insetti in giardino
speriamo che il gatto allaster
ricorrendo merlino ma un occhiale
sterline con un altro pronto al salone
gatto col ricatto ogni tanto si arrabbia
pensiero atti non è normale normale
perché il gatto inseguire berlino
[Risate]
quando scusate la finestra di tanto si
chiude da sola
queste erano alcune delle novità è sia
un super felici perché vedrete dove
quattro bellissime non vedo l'ora
siamo felicissimi del canale fra gente
sempre di più vista di scriverti
tantissimi più state parlando
tantissimi i nostri video quindi siamo
felicissimi che ringraziamo tantissimo
che si rispetti che guardano via ogni
giorno e che non manca mai
all'appuntamento vi ringraziamo un sacco
e anche chi mi segue sul canale
dell'italia del canale digitale stiamo
olio pubblicato in libia berlino e
divertenti quindi andate a vederli mi
raccomando ora vi dico cosa c'è in palio
nel giveaway e come partecipare allora
in palio nel giveaway
abbiamo innanzitutto il mio libro
perché volevate di più quando gli ho
chiesto cosa volete in palio è il mio
libro che potete vedere qui sotto
anzi li facciamo spoiler di una falsa e
allora eccolo qua è bellissimo se lo
avete già comprato se ce l'avete già
bravissimi innanzi tutto benissimo lo
stesso però se volete potete regalarlo
qualche vostro amico qualche vostro
compagno di scuola
avremo una pagina a caso è bellissimo lo
adoro fatemi sapere se già se lo mette
comunque in palio ci sarà un mio libro
si voglia c'era un kit slime mi metto la
foto qua è un kit slime che a 61 pezzi
sono tutte cose che io andrò a comprare
non me le ha regalate a nessuno non
nuove le andrò a comprare io con i miei
soldi
compreso il libro quindi vele spedisco 9
allora questo è un kit con 61 pezzi per
fare lo slime salto un ro precede 61 un
sacco di cose vi faccio vedere allora in
pratica una scatola non so se vi
ricordate
l'avevo già completato noi l'avevamo già
usata questa tua ma ci sono un sacco di
cose dentro allo dei confetti tipo kit
confetti de gli occhietti varie palline
in vari colori poi fishbone a quello
romano dette poi ci sono i fogli dorati
e argentati poi questi sono glitter e
poi un sacco di glitter insomma quindi
tutto quello che vi può servire per
seguire le ricette del mio libro resort
live e farne tantissimi di slime insomma
in questo kit slime della helbers in
pratica in questo kit ci sono delle
colle colorate brillantinati
anche voi che vi servono a preparare lo
stesso di slide dal mio libro
voi ci sono due colle dovrebbero essere
tutte due trasparenti o forse una
bianche una trasparente penso che siamo
protegge transparency and me resta che
sapete le foglie della henderson le
migliori per fare lo slime poi ci sono
due bottigliette attivatori perché mi
ricorrervi
ma come avete detto che non riuscite ad
attivare lo snai non sapete con casa
attivarlo anche l'anti genitori
soluzione per legge qui si stanno già
gli attivatori così non dovete usare o
la borsa o la soluzione per lenti il
bicarbonato e ci sono già gli attivatori
potete aiuti di stato perché c'è sempre
il tè quindi questo kit è fantastico
quindi queste tre cose saranno nel vivo
waber in giro direttamente da amazon nel
senso che io le compro su amazon e poi
mette il vostro indirizzo per inviarli
invece di farle inviare da me e poi
andare io a rispedirle faccio prima
spedirle direttamente da amazon si sono
tre cose fantastiche per partecipare
dovete essere iscritti ovviamente al
canale e avere la campanella attivata
poi essere iscritti al secondo canale
quindi anni the stories doni netto il
link qua nella descrizione e attivare la
campanella poi essere iscritti al canale
di vitale che trovate con il nome il
canale di vita levi la facciamo immagine
dove come fare molto
si è fatto da sé attivatela campanellina
anche per il canale di vita dovete
stemmi e messo in sua grande summit e
instagram il nome anita stories quindi
stemmi temi
se volete potete anche seguire un
berlino su instagram per chiesto
pazienza grande berlino il cagnolino
innanzitutto non una descrizione steve
howey scade i pad e il 12 maggio quindi
mi raccomando fate tutto quello che e
necessario poi scrivete un commento qua
sotto
scrivete cosa avete fatto di tutti gli
step scrivete se avete se vi siete
iscritti attivato le campanelle per i
nostri tre gare scrivetelo tutto nei
come voi sceglierò un commento a caso
con un sito che sceglie i commenti a
caso però dovete aver seguito tutti
questi step altrimenti non quando vedo
poi il commento vedo che non vi siete
iscritti e non mi avete seguito eccetera
eccetera non sarà valido linio valutato
che questo sempre temi in piazza non
rivelano un sacco di cose super
fantastiche ed emozionanti cioè di
tenetevi pronti sta rispetti
un bacione norme vi lasciamo 4
castellini a supplicare per vedere i
nostri altri video
mettete su quello che preferite una
visione ciao